ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money from the
headquarters of ramsey solutions it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey
your host dr john deloney host of the dr
john deloney show and best-selling
author is my co-host today as we talk
about your relationships your career
your work your money and your life and
we're gonna do it all right in front of
you it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five tyler's gonna start us off
in atlanta hey tyler welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call
appreciate your time sure what's up
okay uh i got a situation which just
recently sold a property uh after the
mortgage paid off netted a million
dollars well i hate it when that happens
oh what a bummer man
you all okay you're gonna be okay you're
gonna be all right
i'm i'm above ground so i think we're
gonna be all right congratulations man
that's awesome
but what i'm trying to figure out is do
i invest
we've got another property that's got a
mortgage on it with a great interest
rate
i've considered rebuilding the house
that we just sold and i think it's going
to be appreciated
right out of the gate but i just try to
look for some direction on what you
would recommend
um where were you living in this house
it was our primary residence yes okay
where are you going to live
uh we have a second home too
all right is that where you're going to
live
that's where we're living now yeah is
that what you're going to live for five
years or whatever
i mean what's this building thing
well it was a lake property you know you
own lake properties and stuff but the
market where it came from is just
through the roof
and it's cheaper to build one right now
than to buy one in this area another
like another lake property
correct okay all right is that i mean if
you're gonna use the money for that
that's fine you got rid of one lake
property you're gonna build another one
and net out some bucks it sounds like
right
well i would have a paid off lake house
yeah yeah i would have no no mortgage on
us still have a mortgage on the the home
that we're in now and what are y'all on
that but we've been
uh 300 000 okay well what are you going
to spend on the lake house
probably a million
okay what do you make
uh combined between my wife and i as
150.
okay
well you've done really well
congratulations
um my temptation would be to go and get
my house paid off and then
back into the lake house maybe a year
later or something or
um and maybe do a
not do a million maybe doing 800 or
something i don't know but
it sure would be cool if out of all this
uh surplus that you've ended up with
here when you took your chips off the
table if you ended up completely debt
free when the smoke cleared wouldn't it
yes that would be very nice and i think
that's probably my goal if i'm in your
shoes and i think that's what you're
asking
um but you've got a lot of options on
the table you can do whatever you want
to do
you've done really well congratulations
we you know i i'm always going to move
towards 100 debt freedom as fast as i
can within reason and you're in a case
like yours there's no reason to panic
uh but if you're gonna go buy a build a
lake house a second home a toy while you
still have a mortgage on your residence
i'm i'm not doing that
i'm gonna get rid of my mortgage
and be debt-free and then i'm going to
start talking about buying toys
um but i do have to keep in mind that
the money just came from the last lake
house deal so you got it you know
there's nothing nothing on fire here no
panic here but i'm
if i reverse engineer this i would i
borrow on my home to build a lake house
not in a million years
and if effectively that's what you're
ending up doing i wouldn't do that yeah
i think i'd be debt-free before the
day's over and yeah i'll write a check
today pay off the house then we'll
figure out what we're doing from there
um and
you know if you're gonna do another lake
house that'd be great but um and as you
know i'm a big fan of lake houses
because i have one it's my favorite one
of my favorite places on the planet
anyway thanks for the call hyman's with
us in
philadelphia hi hyman how are you
hey know dave
nice nice to get to you thank you for
taking my call sure
um i have a question
i recently a storm had hit the
philadelphia chester county area and
the federal government that came in and
said for folks that had damages uh you
can apply it for some kind of support i
did fill out the application a lot of
folks got um grants and for me they gave
me a loan oh no why'd you do that
yeah everybody else that grant but they
get they offered me a loan i think yeah
i know i'm passionate about my i don't
need a loan yeah with my income
um but so that's what i was calling i
kind of knew the answer that he was
gonna ask well i have about um 45k
in a in a in a emergency fund money
market and i have about 35 about 44k in
a saving account um my basement is
destroyed uh the kids can't plan it and
i want to assist if i should
take one and take the fixed basement
uh it's they they are they said it's
about 20 23
contractors and also the credit so you
can fix it for 20 grand and you have 80
grand
i got 44. yes i thought you said you had
44 and you had 40 and something else
in a in a money market that counts yeah
so you have 80. you have 80 000. don't
do this don't get connected don't take a
loan from the government all of that you
know that you know that
you have the money fix the basement
don't go in debt to the government god
help us
yeah i just paid off you know sixty
thousand dollars in debt so and the only
thing we have to do is our mortgage
is nothing that's awesome i'm glad you
did that but that doesn't have anything
to do with you taking a loan from the
government and worse don't go back into
debt you just got out of just got out of
it man
um can i sneak another question i know
you'll go in time i don't know i don't
know are you going to borrow money from
the government or not if it's about
borrowing money from the government hey
just hang up
are you going to borrow money i know i
i'm not going to borrow it i know the
answer in that one okay my daughter then
you can ask another question
yeah my daughter is 14 she's about to go
to college we play like i said i just
paid off 6 thousand non-debt no car
payment only car payment only my debt i
have is mortgage
um should we should i be paying extra on
my mortgage are putting more money
toward her college fund she got about
four more years you need to have a plan
for her to go to school debt-free
and uh and beyond that you put money
towards your mortgage but you need to
have a plan you need to map out where
she's going to go what it's going to
cost
and how much she's going to work and how
much she's going to go getting
scholarships
and um
how her grades are doing and all of that
kind of stuff and then we go okay this
is what it's going to cost and here's
the money and we're going to set our
goals now five years out
and then based on that you can tell if
you have any money left over
to pay extra on the mortgage but baby
step five is kids college six is pay
extra
on the mortgage i've got we've got a
book out that was a bestseller called
debt free degree it's how to go to
college debt free
i'll send you a copy of that and you
guys can unpack that together
and make out a plan i actually want you
to get four colleges
two one or two that she thinks she wants
to go to one that's in your area and
then a what i would call a fallback like
a like a
here's a good place we can go to college
it's going to be an economical choice
and run those numbers that david's
talking about on all of them and you can
spread them across and see what your
options are and what you're thinking
about yeah and then you can save twitter
you can ask yourself yeah is that degree
over there really worth more than that
same degree over here exactly you can
ask yourself that question and you'll
probably say nope
but it's a good idea to lay it out it's
a great exercise
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money parker's in phoenix
arizona hey parker what's up
hey how are you guys
better than i deserve sir what how can
we help
thank you for everything you do
my wife and i have been married for two
years and we're just sorting out our
life insurance
and we have a friend that works for one
of the big
life insurance companies and instead of
a traditional term life insurance plan
they offered us a decreasing term life
insurance plan
and we're trying to grapple with what
that means and it's a good option for us
so
for roughly the same cost as a 20-year 1
million dollar traditional term plan
it would start out
at 1.7 million
and then after six years
it would drop 600 000 to 1.1
um and then after 10 more years it would
drop another 400 000
um and then it would stay at
700 000 for the last few years for
roughly the same cost as what
as a million dollar traditional
a million dollar level with that company
correct and i know the goal with term
life insurance is to self-insure over
the period of the term exactly but it
also seems like with inflation and with
raises over that time that the term or
the the payout at the end if we ever
needed it would seem quite a bit smaller
so i'm just trying to grapple with those
two principles well as you get out of
debt and as your wealth increases and as
your children age your need decreases
so decreasing term actually follows your
life
technically speaking
okay
meaning that as your net worth increases
because you're you've got more and more
and more in your 401k so instead of
having 50 000 in your 401k you got a
half million in your 401k that lowers
your need
for insurance agreed
and if you paid off all your debt your
half million dollar house during that
time that lowers your need
during that time if your kids are 16
years old they're gonna be at home three
or four more years if you died versus if
they're six months old and they're gonna
be there 20 years if you died that
lowers your need for math and most your
need for money does that make sense so
decreasing term technically does follow
the idea of becoming self-insured
gradually however
having said that
the products typically aren't that great
typically the level term insurance when
you shop it will beat the decreasing
term substantially and i'm going to
guess the reason it's not is the company
you're talking to has structured their
products poorly so i'll bet if you shop
that term insurance you're probably
going to find a much better deal
on level term insurance 15 to 20 year
level term the difference in that and
decreasing term across the whole market
is not substantial and it doesn't
decrease
so i've always bought level
with the idea that i was just going to
let it go when i needed to um
you know so uh
who's the company
uh new york life i believe yeah not a
term company a whole life company their
term products suck and are too expensive
so my theory is proven right
so what you need to do is go to
xanderinsurance.com and shop level term
and it will whip new york life's butt on
price bad i mean like embarrassingly bad
and so all of a sudden you're going to
be able to buy 1.7 in level term for
what those goobers are trying to sell
you the decreasing term policy for
that's what i'm gonna think you'll find
i might be wrong but i don't think i am
i've done this a while and i've pissed
off new york new york life before so
wouldn't be my first time but no i
wouldn't i wouldn't buy
uh and no i wouldn't do business with
them
um period so uh you know go to zander
and zander is an independent broker
they're not new york's captive they only
sell for one company new york life
that's all they sell for
and so your friend's sweet but he's not
got very good products
and um his company's not sweet i love it
when you're ambiguous with your answers
people people don't know what i'm
thinking i just yeah i wonder when
there's one company out there i just
don't notice they love them or not love
them subtle yeah
go to xander insurance and let them shop
a bazillion different companies and get
you a good deal dude really you're going
to see a completely different world
than you've already seen on insurance
but it's a good question because we get
to discuss these
products that are out there and the
differences
and so the reason
to recap
that
i
personally own and recommend
15 to 20-year level term insurance
instead of decreasing term when actually
what i teach is
your need is decreasing the reason i do
is the price is not enough differential
to take the decreased coverage you don't
get enough for the decreased coverage if
the decrease coverage was like way
cheaper and let the decreasing term
going down i'd do it yep doing heartbeat
because it matches up with what we teach
but the actual products
they dis-incentivize you from buying
them very few people are
uh
and term insurance is just so stinking
cheap anyway yeah level term insurance
is cheap anyway so i'm surprised there's
not more companies that offer a product
like that
that at a discounted rate well they used
to and then what's happened is term
insurance has just gotten so expensive
so it's got so inexpensive it's just the
cost of a pizza i mean
you can buy for nothing it's just uh 20
year level term insurance on a 30 year
old is it's cost of a pizza
and so um it just
stopped being
when it was super expensive then every
little thing mattered because it changed
the numbers you know but it's just not
that much money when the smoke clears on
it versus what he's going to find
there'll be a lot of money difference
there elizabeth is in baltimore hi
elizabeth welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks so much how's it going
better than i deserve how can we help
um so
i am about 22 years old i'll be 23 um
this coming june so i right now um i
have a pretty good job i work in the
city i i live on my own in my own
apartment
um and i'm i consider myself debt-free
only because my mom i'm lucky enough
that my mom pays off my student loans
that's how i'm building credit though
right now i don't have a credit card
um i'm kind of trying to figure out how
to start building my credit in the best
way and i also hope to like the next
maybe
five to seven years start look at maybe
building a house building a house
somewhere but inflation is kind of
scaring me recently so i'm trying to
figure out what is my best way to set
myself up for success since i'm at a
kind of i guess good point in my life
where i don't have so much debt you are
so cool you're on the ball for 22. well
done thank you very cool and you're new
to us how'd you find us um so actually
i've since i've been so into um you know
home builds and all that stuff recently
um there was a girl on tick tock i can't
remember her name but she talked about
how she paid off i think
350 000 of debt so you jumped over and
found us where
um so she i found you guys on spotify
and she told me i'll be listening to you
um
so i was like i gotta go take a listen
elizabeth what we teach what we teach
folks is the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth is to get out
of debt and stay out of debt
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income
okay now that you need to have that you
need to have that framework for me to
answer this question because what that
would mean is is that i don't want you
going into debt
that's what it means right and so what
that means is you're not going to go in
debt to build your credit so that you
can build your debt so that you can go
into debt to build your credit so that
you can go into debt to build your
credit so that you can go into debt to
build your credit which is what people
do with the fico score
the fico score does not mean anything a
high fico score all it means is you've
been playing kissy face with the bank
it does not mean you have money it does
not mean you have money
yeah it means you paid the bank your
money that's all it means so i i don't
want it's a false measure of winning
it's a lie
and you're not winning if you have a
high fico score if you have an 800 fico
score i'm sorry for you you paid
probably a hundred thousand dollars in
interest to build that
yeah somebody else a nice business it's
kind of like playing those video games
where you buy stuff for your video game
it's not real
right yeah so don't do it don't go build
your credit elizabeth you know what my
credit score is i have no idea that's
what it is i don't know we don't have
one could care less we quit borrowing
money we don't have a credit score how
do you get a mortgage you do manual
underwriting remember that phrase
when you get ready to build elizabeth
manuel underwriting but the fastest way
that you get ready to out do inflation
and get to build your house is stay out
of debt don't go into debt so you can
have the opportunity to go into debt so
that you can build your score so that
you can have the opportunity to go into
debt so that you can build your score so
that you can have the opportunity to go
into debt don't get caught up in the rat
chasing this wheel and keep these banks
furniture bought for them
buy your own furniture
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
well 2021 was crazy
left a lot of people feeling burned 2022
is your fresh start your wake-up call
we're running our new year's sale right
now so you can get up to 73 off our
best-selling books assessments and
envelopes and that includes a brand new
book baby steps millionaires that'll
show you the quickest right way to
become a millionaire or if you're
looking for a better way to manage your
cash well check it out the cash envelope
systems are there all kinds of stuff on
sale for only 10 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com
in the store including the total money
makeover including a whole bunch of our
other things and the brand new book is
for sale but not for ten dollars baby
steps millionaires it's on sale at
ramseysolutions.com
as well
check out the store
so couple things in the news we need to
comment on john like last week we talked
about the
government um basically states attorneys
general several of them banded together
and sued navient for what it may be one
of the largest settlements in u.s
history navient being required to settle
for 1.83 billion dollars
and 995 million of that was uh in
restitution 1.7 billion dollars was in
student loans that had to be forgiven
because they were fraudulently
made or fraudulently managed
and we made a lot of fun with that and
had a lot of fun with that because it's
it's absolutely a bizarre thing that
navient just got
they got clocked i mean they got their
clock cleaned one of the largest
billions and billions and billions
naviance forgiveness is now more than
the federal government's forgiveness of
student loans but they didn't do
anything wrong but they didn't admit
anything wrong now here's what's
ridiculous though okay
here's how people here's how the media
and i swear some of you people
so you would think that the headline
would read
navient
is a fraudulent scumbag
yes that ripped people off and the
government took them down
instead cnn says more than 400 000
student loan borrowers will get debt
relief from navient what a gift like
navient is just a charitable
organization thank you cnn for your
misleading headline
now when you read down in the cnn
article it actually does say that they
were sued yeah but you know the but the
headline is like navient is a charitable
organization oh you know we just thought
we wanted to help
because we're just those kind of people
in bc navient plans to cancel some
student loan borrowers loan that i
wonder who qualifies thanks headline
thanks that's awesome navi isn't that
great they're just they're just the best
people
you're losing your mind out there
america and why would nbc and cnn do
that you would think they would take the
side of the consumer and go
crooks
caught on tape your loan might be
forgiven because they were sued into
oblivion
you know instead it's like navient is
going to help you
he's like
jeez man come on guys you finally get a
real bad guy yeah and you don't even
know what to do with him
you finally get a bad guy that you
didn't make up you got a real one and
then we let it just roll off
and then this is this is just
so i'm there was a little uh uh
a kids game
on the internet uh uh an app or uh
i don't even know what it was i think it
was called animal farm okay and you
would build your little farm is that
right james is called animal farm you
remember what i'm talking about animal
crossing is what we're hearing crossing
or something like that it was like this
empire thing or something but you built
your farm
and you you tilled the farm
and you know you eventually you know and
you made like pretend internet money
that didn't exist
that's what it is
farmville that's what it was called
and your kid could spend you know and
then it got to where you could actually
go on the site and give real money to
get pretend money
to buy a pretend pig
i make my kids go outside and work a
real garden without
this is like a virtual pig it's not a
pig okay it's a virtual pig it's a
pretend pig it doesn't really exist it
exists only on the internet it's not
there's no oinking no bacon gonna happen
okay
just a just a it's a virtual
pig it's not real and you could build
your whole farm out with this and it was
all pretend and it was all virtual and
it was a kid's game and so i run into
this guy at an entree leadership event
and i'm like it's him the guy that
created the game no no the kid's 19
years old and his dad's with him and his
older brother who's 26 is there and i'm
like so what kind of a business you all
got well we build uh
apps for farmville
and i'm like you mean like add-on like
you don't own farmville no but we we
help people
do better at their farm their pretend
farm that's not really there
and i'm like really
and so how much did you make he goes
well i made six million dollars last
year
on this app my dad works for me and so
is my older brother he's 19.
and i'm going crazy i thought it was the
neatest
thing that this young entrepreneur could
figure out a way
to sell an app on pigs that aren't
really there and get real money and got
real money
and kids are paying them serious money
to get started what is happening
that's not really there well then it
started occurring to me that we now have
an entire
probably two generations that are raised
up with a screen in front of their face
and to them what's on that screen is as
real as the real thing
when you say virtual
to someone my age it means not real
it's a projection it's sort of it's
virtual it's not if i
virtually made it i didn't make it
okay if i if you know i didn't get there
you know i'm saying that's the literal
definition only have a million dollars
no you don't it means you don't and so
um and so that that's uh that means you
have maybe a little bit less but not
quite you know you're not it's not real
you're not there and so when you say
virtual now to this entire two
generations
to them it's very real because they've
lived their entire life in it
and so when meta hits
and now we're selling nfts and
now walmart and nike
and
under armour are selling nfts and now
you can
walmart's setting up now for you to have
your
your pretend house it's not really there
it's only on the internet like your
little farmville
and if you want to buy pretend drapes to
go in your pretend house because that's
what virtual means it means pretend not
real it's not really there there's
nothing there it's it's not real it's
virtual
and but now walmart is setting up
appears to be venturing into the
metaverse with plans to create its own
cryptocurrency and collection of nfts
the big box retailer filed several new
trademarks last month that indicates its
intent to make and sell
virtual
goods well let me help you with this
virtual goods is an actual oxymoron if
it's a good it's not virtual
and if it's virtual it's not a good a
good this little coffee cup right here
is an actual coffee cup it actually
exists here's some of the goods
including virtual electronics virtual
home decorations virtual toys virtual
sporting goods and so what we've got is
the kids that grew up playing farmville
are now going to
virtually furnish their virtual house at
walmart
oh my gosh well they didn't happen while
they didn't pay off their student loans
they don't even live in the real world
they virtually live
because it's safer in there inside that
little box than it is out here with the
with the crazy button humans with real
drapes that fall off real windows well
and try hanging real drapes that'll help
you get a divorce but yeah exactly just
i mean but these drapes virtually hang
themselves it's happening
this is yeah yeah unless you have to
hire virtual maloney is there not a
psychological disorder at play here dude
we we have i'm telling you it's escape
man it's escaping to a fantasy world
checking out of the challenges of our
real world and we're going to a place
where we can control the variables
because we cannot do it in our real life
that's exactly right
and now we're spending money to do it
real real real money for things that
aren't really there there in case
anyone's forgotten we're in not real
money to the tune of
what 20 25 trillion dollar like yeah
well there's just so virtual that we're
just moving none of it's real anymore
but uh well your generation did that
well that's true my generation did do
that
last ten years we've doubled the uh
the 10-year look back thing that's going
around yeah you doubled the uh
the debt at the government level that's
another discussion but oh my god
this is so this is uh i i rarely say i'm
not saying it's not okay to play video
games and if you want to spend some
money on your video games or whatever
it's fine but when you psychologically
escape to another world to the point
that you don't own real drapes but you
bought grapes in your pretend house you
got issues for electronic walmart
darling it ain't real
it sounded like my aunt
i don't even know what
what do you say to this
it's virtual
it's virtually oh this is not real but
it's so interesting because it's the kid
made so much money i'm so enthralled
with it but it's scary about what it
means to about this generation
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today you can be sure and check
him out on the dr john daloni show as he
discussed relationships mental health
boundaries
all kinds of uh wild and crazy things
that people get into it's a
very entertaining and informative and
inspiring on dr john dalani show one of
the many ramsey network podcasts that we
have out these days he's absolutely
doing great work nabeel is with us
nabeel is in atlanta hi nabil how are
you
hi dave thank you for having me on the
show sure what's up
so i'm a 23 year old with about 80 000
85 000 saved i've got about 25k in my
roth ira and 401k and about 60k in
investments in index funds which with
i'm looking to purchase my first home
wow where'd you get all that
so i work at a job i've just been
following your principal since i
graduated college and i've kind of every
stimulus every uh piece of extra money
that i've gotten i'm kind of just put
away and tried to save so not counting
your roth you got like 145 000 bucks
no no so it's it's total of about 85
it's about 60 in the oh the whole game
is that okay
yes okay got it um
so basically i make about 120 000 uh the
job that i really relocated to about six
months ago and because i'm already
traveling i just moved back in with my
parents so i'm looking to buy a home
with which i would use as both the
primary residence and also
simultaneously rent part of it out to
make up for the cost of me not being
there because of my work travel what are
you doing it's now a good
so essentially i'm a project manager
setting up new warehouses across the
country
man you're killing it good job dude
you're killing them thank you
do you like the job you like trouble
yeah i do i do i'm only uh it kind of
complicates the
housing because i'm only in
my home city for about four days a month
i'm kind of just ongoing hotels uh so
that's why i'm trying to see whether now
it's kind of a good time for me to buy a
townhouse or a small house in the 250 to
300 000 range i would purpose and how do
i kind of find it i wouldn't either i
wouldn't i wouldn't either you're not
there enough to manage it
that's it pops freeze and bust the whole
thing out before you get back
okay so how would you kind of recommend
that someone like myself uh in the
coming years say i were to stay in the
shop how would you recommend i
pursue homeownership i would later but
right now i think you're being very wise
to listen here's the thing
i owning a home
uh crap breaks
whether you're there or not
and it's just it adds you have a very
simple very clean very efficient life
and i would let someone else manage the
domicile
rather than you having a
let's say you had a roommate that
decided they want to sell all your
furniture on ebay while you were gone
that could happen
it's happened before
um
and so you get back the roommate's going
all your stuff's gone and you file a
police report but
yeah i mean i've got a relatively new
house and i just got a report last week
i got to replace an air conditioner the
whole unit the whole thing yeah i don't
know why you want to do all that right
now i i think there's plenty of time as
young as you are to own a piece of real
estate i would wait at least 12 months
maybe 24 months and if you're home four
days
a month
rent the ritz
yeah i didn't think about that go to the
nicest hotel in atlanta go to the ritz
buckhead it's a nice property i stayed
there and just just for four nights
your life will be so much better people
will like bring food to your door and
stuff and then you can come in your room
and set it up and you don't have to go
buy food wash your towels it's called
room service and you don't have to
change the beds i mean it's a that's
what i would do and just have a really
nice efficient life and let my energy be
spent my spiritual emotional physical
energy be spent on something other than
home ownership for four days a month
okay that makes a lot of sense but but
i'm okay now long term i do want you to
buy so let's set a goal 25 years old you
buy
because i think your life will change i
don't think you want to do this
indefinitely
this gypsy thing yes that makes sense
yeah it's going to be i mean that like
this is not conducive to family life
right
no definitely not it's very much you're
living like a nomadic life yeah yeah
it's kind of cool you're getting to see
a lot of stuff you're a young guy it's
kind of a you know little uh uh yeah
like you said nomadic that's all cool
all that's kind of fun i would do it i
definitely do it if i was your agent
single i think it's kind of all day long
you get to see a lot of cities and
america's got some wonderful cities you
get to see some
cities that aren't wonderful that are
out there too if you do this for two
years you're gonna blink and you're
gonna you could have 250 000 in cash
yeah just sitting there just keep piling
up some money and then just go buy you a
house but i not for four days a month no
i wouldn't
i like real estate but it is not it is
the un the thing that nobody talks about
with rental real estate or personal
residence is either one is they break
yeah and you have to have people come
over and fix crap you know and or fix it
yourself with your little youtube video
or whatever it is you're doing but oh my
gosh and on
and and there's
entire portions of my life have been
used up on broken stuff
around real estate you know that you
don't have to have if
on the short term right if you're in his
situation so i i like to have in my all
my life back my bandwidth back to do
like fun stuff
or whatever or the four days you're home
just relax yeah and just have no house
have some peace no hassle no hassle no
house or no house that's fun that's fun
it's fun to have no hassle caleb is with
us in louisville kentucky hi caleb how
are you
better than i deserve dave thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um
so i'm 17 i'm going to be 18 a week from
today
i'm going to pursue a degree in computer
science to be a software developer
i'm hoping to to kind of save some cash
and cash flow as much as i possibly can
um so to do that i can be transitioning
out of my current job at a fast food
restaurant
and gonna start doing uh broad ass
food delivery
but i know that is structured as an
independent contractor kind of thing and
not
like taxes aren't withholded
automatically correct
[Music]
so i'm just wondering as somebody that
you know knew all this uh
what are some resources and uh i'm
estimating between 15 and 20 tax
um and just for your recommendations
with that i would set aside 25 of
everything you make for taxes and you're
supposed to file quarterly estimates
because you have your income tax and you
also have both sides of social security
which amounts to 15.3 on its own
okay they call it self-employed tax but
all it is is double your social security
because small business people are
supposed to be supported by the
government you know you know how that
works right
so but it's double right it's double
yeah i pay double
and so uh because your employer pays the
other half when you're a wage earner
but when you're self-employed you get to
pay both sides and you pay the income
tax on top of that you may not have any
income tax but you'll have at least the
15.3
percent of fica
and the self-employment tax and so and
you have to pay it quarterly so if you
said it's going to set aside a fourth of
everything and you'll have the money
okay so it'll be paid quarterly and not
like every spring like normal taxes well
your taxes have to be filed but you're
supposed to file and pay
quarterly estimates on your taxes
like you're withholding on yourself kind
of a thing and it's it's a one-page
thing it's not complicated math it's
easy to do you put in there what you
made and what your expenses were and
what therefore what your profit was
times your tax rate and you send them
you send them a check
and that's just through the irs yes it's
to the it's to the irs and it's very
easy to do and if you need some help
with it just get in touch with one of
our
tax endorsed local providers they can
either help you with it over the phone
or they'll just tell you how to do it
or you can pay them a little bit and
they'll do it for you but um you can
also you you may have some business
deductions uh you may be able to deduct
your mileage or your fuel or something
uh if you're door dashing you should be
able to do something with the car i
suspect
um but um yeah can you deduct your
mileage and your depreciation and all
that i mean
yeah but you just got to be real careful
with it you got to log it properly and
all that kind of stuff so
but the bottom line is yeah you'll make
a lot more money but you're going to
have a lot more taxes
uh as a self-employed person and you'll
be fine you'll be fine you should do
this and i'm going to send you a copy of
the book debt-free degree because i
don't want you to hope you can go to
school debt free i want you to do it
i want you to do it for sure don't
borrow a dime
don't borrow it
this
is the ramsey chat
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we talk about your
relationships your work your money and
your life the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five two two
five
emma is with us emma is in orlando to
start off this hour hi emma how are you
hi dave nice to talk to you you too
what's up
um
so i am
i just turned 20 i am moving to orlando
for my first job in the industry
and my job is going to require that i
travel around the city so i am looking
into getting a car but i wanted to know
what would be the best way to go about
that given my financial situation you
have your money
yeah
yes i do how much money do you have
so i budgeted 10k for a car i already
have that in cash and that was the
amount that i was um
working up
to
i was working up to buying a car for 15
000
but i only have ten thousand right now
and i have another 10k in emergencies
um in emergency savings
so
i
wanted to get a car that was around the
family of 15k because that would be the
one that would give me all the safety
features that i wanted and
um yeah but i'm in a position where i
need to get the car now
and
i don't know what to do about that if i
should be getting a cheaper smaller car
that probably wouldn't be too safe but
that would allow me to save up for the
more expensive one or should i just go
ahead and dip into my emergency savings
and buy the bigger safer car now and
then just rebuild it from there okay
what what is your income
um so the job i haven't started it yet
but i'll be starting
within the next couple of weeks it would
be 60k before taxes and you'll be doing
what yeah what's the industry
um engineering ah very good very good
and um
you so you've got an engineering degree
yes excellent way to go okay i'm gonna
answer your question and then i'm gonna
give you a smart alec answer too okay
okay
can i do that
sure okay number one yes take five
thousand out of your emergency fund pay
cash for the fifteen thousand dollar car
five thousand dollar emergency fund with
you starting a new engineering job
making 60s gonna be plenty for right now
and then let's beef that emergency fund
back up
a little bit but you're not you're not
in danger by doing that okay so you get
your wish okay
now but the snarky part is you have to
learn this lesson
you cannot rationalize on purchases or
you won't make wise ones
the statement that the difference in
safety of a fifteen thousand dollar car
and a ten thousand dollar car is
substantial is absolute hogwash
you just wanted a nicer car and that's
okay i think you can afford it i want
you to go get it i just told you to go
buy it but the difference in safety of a
ten thousand dollar car or a fifteen
thousand dollar car doesn't exist there
is no difference in the safety that's
bull
okay all right so just don't you got you
have to watch doing that to yourself
because i do it to myself i did it for a
lot of my life and i'm 61 years old near
20. okay so uh
and as long as you tell yourself these
lies in order to get something that you
what just say out loud i just wanted a
nicer car and i have the money
and i want to know if it's okay to push
a little bit into that emergency fund to
do it i just want it but don't don't
don't tell me it's safety and don't tell
yourself more importantly than me that
is safety because
you get you get slaughtered in either
one of them or you can just get bumped
into with either one of them and they'll
fall apart either one it doesn't matter
i mean
their differences are the difference in
type of car just take out the you know
a big suv
versus
john's tiny little girly prius
you know
the difference in that is safety okay
there's safety difference in those two
things
i'm left here it comes here comes no i'm
saying my family
my wife and two kids drove that prius
for the last seven years and we actually
bought it from a friend of ours for ten
thousand dollars whoa you know what i
mean and so like the the car a ten
thousand dollar car was good enough for
my wife and kids until she said
i don't feel safe in a roller skate
anymore can we get something a little
bit bigger pregnant roller skate there
you go that's what we used to call them
so all to say is for ten thousand bucks
you can protect your family now that was
before the car type of car is more
important than what it costs there you
go for safety yes the size how much
metal is around you the actual features
and i lost a good buddy in a two f-250
this past year in a row so
living your life like that you're right
it's justification just say what you
want me go get it
but the
one of the things that when i went broke
him i had to learn it the hard way and
it just and i i and i can smell it a
mile away for that reason is
um we in america have almost no things
we need
most of our purchases are once
you've got a car i want a better car so
you don't really say out loud i need no
i need a third row no you don't no you
don't you want one be convenient nicer
you have a couch you want a better couch
and that's okay absolutely to buy some
watts but what you want to guard against
is to guard your heart against
creating these
narratives in your head that it's
required
for safety that's or it's required for
uh so it's a neat i needed it i was
forced yeah the other day you have to be
careful out there boundaries of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
yeah talked to a guy the other day he's
talking about he needed a new
hunting scope on his rifle oh definitely
said my granddad hunted for years with
just the iron sights man are you sure
well well he might he might not be good
enough
that's true
that's true he might not be able to get
anything without websites but you know
what i really need what i need
is i need some virtual drapes for my
virtual house steve see but you
virtually wouldn't buy them at walmart
you're that's more of a target guy i'm
more of a kohl's guy i wonder if kohl's
has a virtual or target as a virtual me
i would buy mine at home depot
[Laughter]
me and home depot we're just like this
i'm just saying i've got tools i don't
even know what they do but i bought them
so because i needed them you needed them
so emma that's a good rant uh you're
you're a sharp young lady yeah
20-year-old engineer you've saved money
you've got a plan you're paying cash for
your move you're paying cash for setting
up your house you're paying cash for
your vehicle you're going to be a
millionaire hold on i'm going to send
you a copy of the book baby steps
millionaires by the way the number one
career in the millionaire study that we
did most likely to be a millionaire you
win the superlative engineers engineers
yep number two accountants number three
teachers number four middle manager and
entrepreneurs and number five lawyers
doctors didn't even make the top five
they're number six wow that shocks me
there you go the mds mds are
classically known for not handling money
well yeah pretty much like
music artists and stuff or nfl players
right i mean that kind of stuff right so
[Music]
but hey they still made number six they
made number six so some of them are
doing it
hey this is fun this is fun we're glad
you're here america thanks for joining
us dr john dolone and dave ramsey right
here on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
true or false
it's possible for you to become a
millionaire
it's probable
that you would become a millionaire if
you followed the proven path
to become a millionaire
true and true
see people just like you reach a
millionaire status all the time
by following our baby steps that's why
we wrote the book baby steps millionaire
to show you and prove to you that it can
be done
we've got a best year ever bundle right
now and it includes the brand new book
baby steps millionaires and you get
financial peace university and you get
every dollar the budgeting app all
wrapped up into ramsey plus
and it's the clear steps that are going
to cause you to get there get you out of
debt into wealth and in a position to be
outrageously continuously generous
the best you're ever bundle ramsay
solutions dot com slash
best ramsey solutions dot com slash best
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free free samples free shipping new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from tim in texas
tim writes my 37 year old daughter
recently entered rehab for alcoholism
while it's a difficult situation i'm
very grateful that she realizes she has
a problem and she's seeking help before
she went into rehab i learned that she
had twenty thousand dollars in credit
card debt she's talking about declaring
bankruptcy the tougher love part of me
says she needs it she needs to be
accountable and follow the baby steps
and work through her debt snowball to
pay it off the other part of me said
she's been through a tremendous ordeal
and she needs a fresh start and that i
should pay off the debt for her i'm
fortunate to be in a position where i
can easily do this given my daughter's
addiction pending recovery and negative
financial position what is the best
course of action concerning my
daughter's debt
dave i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this this one gets messy and you've
dealt with this for years and years and
years and years
oh it's your world man i mean it's um
there's a uh
i mean i've got a daughter of that age i
can imagine his heart's broken oh man
and he wants to help yeah and i
immediately wonder
um
if his enabling in the past has
something to do with her addiction yeah
or his yeah
so because he's trying to he's trying to
do it again or or is he just being
compassionate and loving and kind and
yeah you know it's the enablers are
always the nicest people yeah so i think
first it's important to note you take
bankruptcy off the table for twenty
thousand dollars yeah right like that's
off the table point good point um
i
my understanding of the alcoholism rehab
world is like any other rehab world as
you begin to take ownership of your life
one tiny step at a time
and there's something here about
having a goal and 20 000 can feel like a
million i get that when i think of the
dead i owed it looks small but that's
can be a mountain for peop for folks
that you are going to walk alongside her
you're going to
have a weekly breakfast with her that
you're going to set up that you're going
to pay for you're going to check on her
how her budgets are going and what she's
going to get out of that is a new
relationship with you you're going to
tell her about time she's screwed up
with money she's going to get to know
you a little bit better
y'all are going to high-five and
celebrate together she's going to fall
off the wagon you're going to weep
together and you're going to walk
alongside her and then she's going to
get the outsized gif of walking through
and solving this problem with her own
two hands and i think there's a gift
there and maybe at the end you gifted
the last five thousand bucks or lost out
something like that but there's
something about this
what i would do is walk i would just
modify that very very slightly because i
just feel his father's heart on this and
it just compassion is we're dripping off
this email
is his
tears are on there um
and i really don't read any enabler
language no i don't either i don't i was
reading into that but um
uh i think we exactly i do exactly what
you said um and i would pay for her to
go through financial peace university
and maybe even go to class with her yeah
and i would agree to match her
i like that if she pays a thousand i'll
put a thousand oh i like that and so
i'll give her some encouragement but i'm
gonna participate in her healing
i'm not going to try to do it for her
yeah i like that dave i like if you
yeah that's a that's a that's a great
olive branch i like that yeah and you're
you're you're coaching her you're
cheering for now that's you know
contingent upon her being on a budget
cutting up the credit cards so you're
not going back and but as you know a
little part of your overall healing
let's heal your financial situation
simultaneously because they are
overlapped and uh let's do it together
that's fun and i don't know what a great
day i don't know any addiction
challenges that don't have relational
challenges as the foundation so there's
probably some healing here between dad
and daughter that are going to take
place anyway it was just beautiful hey
any anybody that's an addict that's
close to you has pissed you off i'll
just tell you that there's no exception
and probably vice versa because they
piss off everybody around them it's part
of what they do they're manipulative and
they lie and oh it's a mess just a mess
all right micah is with us micah is in
san antonio what's up micah
hey dave um
thank uh bless your heart for helping
these people out um can you help me out
um we'll try what's up man tell me about
it uh i'm trying to get out of the house
i have
uh one thousand dollars
overdrawn in the bank and i'm earning
twelve dollars an hour
uh for my job hold on
[Music]
20. okay what do you do
pepco
what
i prep i prep food for cooking oh food
yeah okay well what are you a thousand
dollars you ever drawn for brother
uh paying for stuff that i thought i had
money for uh
i basically let my pride get to me and
yeah
thinking i had more than i had and so
you're not paying attention you're
disorganized
yeah very disorganized and
yeah
trying to try to stick to some you said
you said trying to get out what do you
mean you're trying to get out of what
house you say
out of the house
and out of debt
and uh whose house your parents house or
what
uh my grandparents house oh okay
okay why do you live with them
uh
[Applause]
because they put up with me
because they enable me
because
yeah and i'm also addicted to video
games too okay
what other addictions do you have
that's about it
okay
how many nights a week are you partying
um
zero actually i just stay home you stay
home and play games
yes
when's the last time you went hung out
with real people doing
kicking a soccer ball or something
or held hands with somebody
a long time okay
so what do you want to do man
i want to make a comfort i want to make
i want to make knives i want to build
knives i want to build weapons
i want to make one shift metal and make
it something better than what it is okay
do you have that do you have that skill
set now is that just a dream you watched
a lot of youtube uh it's a dream good
dream actually so what's your step
between here and fulfilling that dream
um
so far getting out of the house
earning money
i'm also planning on getting into the
army okay and
the army national guard excuse me when
you plan on doing that
uh
this february because
my grandmother's not my grandma my
mother is switching over
insurances on in february
so so you're enlisting
like in the next couple of weeks
uh in the next month
but yeah a couple of weeks yeah so why
why why not go and list tomorrow
and get some structure and some
discipline and some short-term goals
that you can accomplish with the help of
people walking alongside you that seems
like a great alternative right now
it does
and
i currently i did unless before
and i got out because a existence prior
to service condition
that prevented me from going further and
i told them i had bipolar i know
i told him my dad and my his mother have
bipolar okay are you working with a
mental health professional
uh
i'm getting
help i'm
that's the issue i'm trying to get to
i'm trying let's be deal with the
insurance i'm trying if i get the
insurance i can go to
my psychiatrist
so here here's the thing start there
you've got a lot of challenges in your
life you need to go start with a
psychiatrist whatever it takes get that
done tell your grandparents you need to
go see a psychiatrist let's start there
let's get well if you can enlist and
list
otherwise i want you to work on your
mental health just make some money and
then you can think about moving out but
you can do it all in the right order
brother
you got to make you well first man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you're here dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
jeff and amber are in jefferson city
missouri it says on my screen you guys
are debt-free congratulations
thank you very much way to go how much
have you paid off we paid off uh 310
0146 wow
how long did this take
about five and a half years good for you
and your range of income during that
time was 98 000
to up to 120 000. okay with those
numbers i kind of think you paid off
your house did you
yes we did
yeah
[Music]
yeah i'm talking to weird people
yes absolutely way to go jeff and amber
yeah what's this house worth
uh it's worth about two hundred thousand
now and what are you what are you guys
uh
uh it's worth two hundred thousand so
you paid off more than the house yep yes
yes okay
yeah we didn't pay 310 for a 200 house
okay
how old are you
i'm sorry how old are you i'm 48 and
amber's 40. and you have a paid for
house
yes how's that feel
awesome
no debt in the world no debt in the
world it's great yes sir way to go
i love it so tell us what's tell us
about this journey how did you hook up
with this ramsey stuff and what all
happened well i i told him i'd have to
take over the journey part because it
was more me not listening to him um it
started about 10 years ago and jeff took
the fpu class but the church that we
were attending did not offer child care
so i stayed home with the babies and he
yeah which you i know isn't a big no-no
dave caused a lot of fights
he did he did
he'd come home and be all excited about
it and i just kind of roll my eyes and
think he was crazy
but then about a year after that we
bought a bran a brand new car and i had
immediately lost my job
i was blessed with a job loss so i went
and worked for mosers missouri state
employees retirement system and nothing
makes you think more about retirement
than working for a retirement system all
day long
yeah all day long that's what you do so
i decided
i would counsel members on their
wonderful retirement benefit and you saw
certain retirees leave and just darn
near bouncing with joy out of my office
and those were the retirees that didn't
have any debt
and i'm correlating happiness to debt
free yeah i'm making the correlation
yeah i like it
i decided that i wanted to be that
retiree that skips out of the office so
i came home and told jeff with our car
debt truck debt house debt credit card
debt and furniture debt i said jeff
i think i'm ready to listen to you
that's what we did we got on fire with
it those are rare words jeff i hope it
felt good and you gave her the biggest
hug ever the only time i've heard it
that's right that's right
that's exactly i i knew it
once
just once it once was enough though it's
magical it's magical i love it all
kidding aside this is amazing incredible
and so then you guys sit down together
and he had to
kind of catch you back up on the pr the
primer for financial peace university on
what he had been taught right
yes and then we took the class together
and oh there we go then it just went off
from there there we go game off came on
and the debt just starts falling away
and five and a half years later house
and everything you are one of those
happy skipping people yes we are
[Laughter]
neighbors think you're weird skipping
around the backyard
it's so fun
that's so fun yeah that amber ever since
she worked over that place
[Laughter]
so what was the hardest part about this
journey
we've talked about that probably saying
no to the kids
um it's weird but it's a it's a hard
thing to tell them no you can't have
that toy right now it's not in the
budget but um it's also a good thing to
teach your children patience
uh contentment yeah yeah
great things to teach our 13 and 10 year
olds and a culture that has none
so they have a distinct advantage in the
marketplace now yeah right absolutely
because they have common sense and stuff
so can i can i ask you a a more personal
question
sure
if we go back to when you had two little
kids at home
and
he went to fpu by yourself you were at
home by yourself you're kind of doing
your thing he's doing his thing
how has this journey helped your
marriage
oh i i mean i think it's stronger from
that i mean it put us both on the on the
same path and you know we look at the
money situation i mean we look at it the
same way now so it's
you know we're at a point where we're
not putting ourselves back into debt or
anything and it's okay how can we start
cash flowing things and it's just made
us kind of grow stronger together yep
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
budget budget yeah absolutely budget and
you know don't be afraid to be the weird
one i like that
or even let your kids be a little weird
because they don't have it yeah yeah
that's all right weird is good in a
world that's gone nuts you don't be like
the nuts that's right
they're everywhere man i love it way to
go guys so what's your first big thing
now you don't have a house payment what
are you going to do
we're actually getting new carpet in the
house i like it gross it's about time
jeff yeah i know exactly
amber's been telling you that jeff for
weeks all the pets and the kids grow up
first but that's oh
amber what are you getting
yeah the
living room remodel is what i'm calling
it so i'm happy to get that and by the
way her living room is real it's not
virtual that's right
don't buy any virtual drapes from
walmart please buy the real ones buy
real ones yes whether it's walmart or
somebody else i love it you guys are
amazing incredible so proud of you
congratulations thank you how's it feel
to be free
they're just amazing yeah i mean i don't
know why more people don't do it really
exactly
the best part was driving up to the
house the day after and going wait a
minute i don't know anybody for that
yeah mine that was mine
yeah
love it you guys are amazing hey we got
a copy a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you because that's the next chapter
in your story that's for sure where
you're going i'm so proud of you guys
you're an amazing couple i'm so honored
to get to talk to you also going to send
you a copy of total money makeover you
give that to one of your friends and
disrupt their lives okay
it works for me i love it awesome stuff
jeff and amber jefferson missouri i mean
i love this 310 thousand dollars paid
off in five and a half years house and
everything they're weird
ninety eight thousand to one twenty
great story count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
oh can you imagine how hard it would
have been to say
you were right jeff
i know
can you imagine
you were right you know what it's it's
uh it starts with a hey all good change
starts with one moment of humility
oh it all
changes tweetable right there it is all
good change starts with the moment where
you go i got to do something different
this is not working the problem and the
problem is this is what can i do
different it's my fault i got to figure
it out even if it's somebody else's
fault here's where i am what can i do
next oh oh she did it and jeff didn't
run around the neighborhood go and told
you so he said let's do this yeah that's
awesome he bowed his head with her
grabbed her hand and said let's go she
asked a deep question
why don't more people do this
i have to believe it's because they
don't have a picture of it they just
they've never seen they don't have never
felt it they've never seen it
like you know when you lose weight you
realize how good you feel and you can
you know you got a picture of that
i think that people have never felt it
they don't even know what it feels like
well there's
almost nothing around you to support you
in this is what i mean there's everyone
else is doing bonkers yeah and so it you
really it's why we talk so much about
don't be normal normal sucks be weird i
want to give people permission to
to create a new normal a new story to
use your phrasing your your your stories
that in the new book i can't wait till
it gets out and we get to talk about
we're not going to talk about it yet
that's right it's uh man but write a new
story man i mean that's what it is
because you don't you don't see yourself
in that story no it's like somebody
that's rich people story that's somebody
else's story that's my grandpa's story
it's not my story though and i i don't
see how i can get it it's a hopelessness
hope deferred makes the heart sick but
when desire comes it is the tree of life
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
talk about your life your money
your relationships and your work we're
here for all of that at the ramsey show
tara is with us in decatur illinois hi
tara what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can i help
um a little background i'm 30 years old
i'm single i'm halfway through an
electrical apprenticeship
and i'm
currently on baby step two but i will be
debt free by june
so
when i finish my apprenticeship i want
to stay in illinois no more than one
more year so i'm looking to move in the
next three to five years and i'm
potentially considering traveling for a
year before settling down i'm thinking
carolinas or tennessee
so my dad presented me with the option
of if i bought a tiny home i could put
it on the uh he has two properties
basically
that he's combined into one and he said
i could put the tiny home on his second
property and i didn't know what your
thoughts were on that yeah
i wouldn't bother
um there's no proven market for that
um so i don't know if you'll ever get
out of it
um
if you just burned it down when you were
through you could do that i guess
but i can't you i don't want you
thinking that this is going to turn into
money because we don't have any tiny
homes are an anomaly right now there's
no there's no proven resale value
there's not a track record i was just
considering it because
i'm not
i don't rent from a very good company
it's the biggest company here they're
basically slumlords and if i leave my
apartment i'm going to pay a lot more in
rent to stay in a decent area
and i mean the point is if you want to
do this
if you want to do this instead of rent
with no hope of getting anything off the
back of it when you're done
that's okay
but i don't want you buying this
thinking you're going to make money on
it whatever you pay for the tiny home is
what you would have paid in rent and
you're going to lose
just count on losing all of it so if you
sell it for anything you feel good
okay because there's no there's no
proven fact you can actually sell it
when you're done you may have to just
set fire to it and have said say that
was a great three years in the tiny
house okay
but i don't i mean is that how you want
to live for the next three to five years
something to consider
yeah
um
i just
hate living in a place where they won't
fix
my neighbors toilets leaked into my
ceiling for three years
i'm not suggesting you stay there yeah
that's not that's not an option okay
you're leaving the only question is
where you're gonna go okay
and you know one place you could rent
more expensive that's an idea you could
buy something that's another idea uh you
could rent something completely
different have a whole different
situation roommates or whatever that's
another idea
i mean
or you can buy the tiny house but i mean
how do you really want to live but uh
the thing is that a lot of times when
people are looking at stuff like a tiny
house what they're really looking at is
they're looking at the economics of it
and they haven't really thought through
um what living
in a tiny house is going to feel like
yeah because it's by definition tiny
it's little yeah and the bathroom and
the shower and the kitchen and all the
stuff oh right there yeah i mean it's
like it's like the romance of uh you
know the kid just gonna go to manhattan
and live in new york until he finds out
it's a studio apartment oh that's sweet
what studio apartment it means it's one
freaking room okay everything's in one
freaking room that's what that means and
it's the size of your old bathroom yeah
and it's a dorm room yeah it's just like
okay your dorm room at college was nice
with three roommates and it's 1500 bucks
a month
so um this is you know this is you know
it's all real romantic until you start
doing it right and then all of a sudden
it's like
this is like less than fun
so um
that's what i want you to think through
i don't know what you're making as an
apprentice if you could consider buying
something you might want to do that
because you're probably going to you
know you could you could live there long
enough that you would make some money on
it and it would stabilize your situation
ashley's with us in houston texas hi
ashley what's up ashley
hey
um
okay so
how are you guys um thanks for taking my
call i had a couple of questions or just
one major question i guess i just wanted
some general guidance um a little bit
about me
i'm 28
um
i'm a christian god saved me from drug
addiction back in 2015. um i was raised
by addicts
um
so money has been
a huge hurdle for me um thankfully i
don't really have a ton of debt or
anything
i've never had a credit card i've tried
but i've never
been given any lines of credit um
so my core question is um basically
wealth in general and building
um financial stability uh
is a foreign language
it feels so out of reach it feels like
there's a veil between me and this other
reality
where people
live
securely yeah you don't you know it
feels like it feels like
it feels like a foreign language
yeah all i've ever known is financial
insecurity i mean we moved at least once
a year my whole life the bills were
never paid lights getting turned off all
the time and um
god has been good as an adult he's you
know provided he's given me a lot of
things but i find myself
not i've never been able to
i've never been able to
save any money ever yeah john yeah i
always seem to get into some type of
hole okay so
here we go so i'm gonna jump into it
what you're describing you're describing
the poverty mindset right as though this
this air that you've been breathing for
for your whole life right
i want to give you a couple of things
that
can can rattle that cage for you okay
here's the first one you gotta change
your ecosystem and environment and
sometimes that means moving that often
means the people you hang out with and
who you get wisdom from
it's a veil because you don't know those
people and i want you to go find
somebody at your church that will have
coffee with you or a couple of them or
three or four of them women who are 10
or 15 years ahead of you or some guy
running a company that will sit down
with you after church one day on sunday
and talk to you
but i want you to get to know those
people it makes things much more
tangible and they talk in different ways
and they spend their money in different
ways the second one is
often when we grow up with all almost
always you grew up with addicts
the idea of a relationship
is a equals pain because you've been
hurt repeatedly by those people who are
supposed to love you
and what i want to tell you is the only
way to heal and move forward is through
other relationships so you're going to
have to practice being in a relationship
with people sometimes you need a good
counselor for that it sounds like you've
been through a lot of addiction work and
lots of a lot of addiction healing but
that's going to be a group of friends a
group of women that you meet with
regularly to do life with and it's going
to be lo-fi stuff like let's go get
coffee so hang out the room you're
sitting in with these ladies you won't
feel like you fit in yes you'll feel
weird and that's okay
lean into that you tell them hey i feel
weird in here it's okay just it feels
awkward because it is because you don't
know how they think and they all seem to
think alike and you don't think like
they think and what you're trying to do
is change
your thinking right and that's that's
that's how you do it and here's the
third become who you hang around with
here's the third big one
often when you especially when you grow
up with addicts and you grow up in
poverty
everything is about just getting to the
next day and the next day and the way to
lift that mindset is to start thinking
in
two months six months two years five
year plans and it's like going to the
gym you can do a really hard workout and
you look at your body the next morning
and really nothing's changed
but you go again and you go again and
you go again and then six months eight
months ten months later you feel better
you walk better and so it's getting
somebody that can walk alongside you
with this
wealth journey i'm gonna keep a budget
every month even though i'm only getting
10 bucks and the next month it's going
to be 20 bucks i'm going to save i'm
going to follow this budget i'm going to
slowly over time
practice shifting my life and i'm going
to keep going and keep going and keep
going and write it down and start saying
not not in some weird positive
affirmation way but you're changing your
identities what you're doing it's
exactly right i grew up as an addict
you're saying
i'm a young christian who's learning how
to build wealth and who's free
and i'm free of addiction and just write
that down because that's all true but
that's true it's not some weird positive
affirmation it's just the truth that's
true and just speak that the power of
the tongue is amazing hey a great book
to pick up is glass castles you'll laugh
your way through it
you will definitely laugh your way
through it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships
your work your money and your life all
right here on the ramsey show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
matt is with us in portland maine hey
matt how are you
i'm well dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
my wife and i have a what would debut
question uh so i'm 28 she's 27.
uh we just got into our first house a
few months ago
and i'm the super nerd and i have my
amortization schedule
and it looks like if we pause investing
we can pay our house off within three
years
and i wanted to get your opinion on that
what's your household income
uh
on target earnings it's uh just shy of
200 000 a year
okay and what's the balance on your
house
206 000
okay
and so if you were to invest
it would take you four years if you were
to stay with baby steps
that's correct yeah i would stay with
the baby steps
and here's what here's why you're
putting thirty thousand dollars away
which is fifteen percent of your income
in baby step four and you're sheltering
it from the government
and if you and it costs you one more
year to pay off your house
in return
if you if you did it the other way you
pay it all off in three years you can't
go back
and shelter that three years you missed
does that make sense it does you can't
you can't you can't back fund your roth
back three years
and so um
you're going to be there you're fine
you're 28 you're gonna be 31 32 years
old with a paid for house making serious
money with serious money going into
retirement you're going to be a
multi-multi-millionaire
either way there's no dumb answers in
this conversation
but i would personally you ask what they
would do i would go ahead and stick with
the baby steps because that puts another
90 000 bucks
that the government that is growing for
you in the future that the government
doesn't have their hands on yeah and you
can't go backwards and undo that so
actually it puts yeah well another 90
because it's three years three years at
30 000 so that's it's that simple but
yeah good question and the good news is
you're thinking about it which means
you're going to be okay
nothing wrong being a super nerd um you
just don't
over analyze something to the point you
do nothing and you're not that guy
you're you're a man of action so you're
gonna be just fine and i also get the
feeling of
that mortgage sits on you and it just
like it it just weighs on your ways on
your ways on your right it was one year
yeah that's right if it was ten years
we'd think about it yeah change it
changing
from ten years to three yeah let's make
that happen yeah we might we might think
about that but to add one year to the
equation yeah it's not that big a deal
that four years are gonna go by as fast
as three
it's gonna go real quick open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five jonathan's in nashville hey
jonathan how are you
good afternoon dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
uh before we get started i just want to
say i think it is great for so many
people like me and i just got
kind of a direction career path question
for you if you don't mind sure
to be really brief
part-time student belmont sociology
major
i make around 25 000.
got around thirteen thousand dollars in
student loan debt and about a three
hundred dollar a month car lease payment
i'm about to move in with
my grandmother
who's giving me 122 000 to move in just
kind of help take care of the place
assist her go to the grocery store et
cetera
and just kind of seeing
she's going to give you 120 000 to move
in with her
she's pretty well off tell her i'll do
it for 100 jeez louise
wow i know it
made my day
okay so you're gonna have a new
six-figure job working for your
grandmother it's just a one-time gift
though i mean it's not it's not gonna be
recurring but okay uh you know i was
thinking about
should i buy my car
that's on a lease cancer release by
junker
uh you know i was thinking about max
maxing out of roth ira
i want to put i know you don't like this
but i want to put a little bit of money
in bitcoin and gold but
just kind of seeing what you're thinking
you know inflation
excuse me i got covered
too unfortunately
but uh don't give it to me through the
phone
well so you got a lot you got a lot
going on here right
i know i just found this news house why
i just i can't quit i can't quit smiling
but i was also
i'm pretty
go ahead you're you're how old did you
say
26. okay and what is it you want to do
with your life yeah
well you're gonna be a sociology
no it's not even that that's a
sociologist yeah what are you going to
do
i want to i'm pretty pretty good people
i want to go into real estate and what i
was thinking
is inflation's at like 15 percent real
place right now
no
no it's not it's seven you're reading
weird websites bro
it was a bitcoin website yeah stop
reading those websites all of them all
of them get off the internet homie dude
get off the internet
okay uh why are you getting a sociology
degree to go into real estate
well this
you got me sidetracked here
no you've got a side track trust me why
did you why are you getting a sociology
degree to go into real estate
because
i was thinking study associates
basically
human
mass human behavior i was thinking it'd
give me a leg up because i know i'm in
tennessee got people coming from all
over the country
i was thinking that maybe it would help
me
be no that's not it um what happened was
you were you were studying sociology
and you are getting caught up in
anything that shines yes you're like a
bass you're getting ready to get hooked
squirrel
uh so bitcoin gold real estate all these
things are exciting and look like a way
to get rich easy and you need to put the
get rich easy to the side and now
grandma made you rich and now you think
122 000 is rich and it's not no it's not
going to go that far it's it's uh it's
going to disappear so fast it's gonna be
scary how fast that disappears yeah i'm
gonna recommend your grandmother not do
this um
because you're about to lose all this
money all of it if you don't straighten
up and get away from the shiny stuff
because you know that's how bass gets
caught he jumps on a shiny thing so
don't be a bass don't be a dumbass don't
do it
[Laughter]
um
so yeah you're gonna you jump on the
bitcoin jump on gold jump on real estate
nothing down this is this is not the
time for you to do any of this yeah so
you need to slow down
uh you need to sell the car
and get you a paid for ten thousand
dollar car
and pay off your student loan debt and
then take two steps back and ask
yourself
what i want to spend my life
investing in that i love
that gives me richness of soul where i
can be a service to humanity
not how can i take something
and get there quick
because you're you you've got get rich
quick written all over you and it's
gonna bring you pain he who hastens to
be rich will not go unpunished
now this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free white paper
jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality joins
us this hour open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five john is there something in
addition to just um
maturity
emotional maturity
not not chronological or anything else
but just emotional maturity is there
something in addition to that that um
breaks someone away from a get rich
quick because i remember when i
got rich quick
i was chasing get rich quick and nothing
down real estate and i did it i got rich
quick and then i lost everything because
i was stupid he who hates us to be rich
will not go and punish
but there's something that um
greed and fear are the things that drive
that but it feels like that um
there's
a
this looking for a shortcut thing feels
like a maturity thing is it something
else
i i tend to think it's it's about
belonging um the way we're bombarded
with messages now
like we think about that last caller the
way we're bombarded with messages now is
that everybody's doing this thing
and suddenly you're put into this
like this it's like the titanic where
i'll get on the boats man if you don't
get on the boat you're going to drown
and i think it's just this and then you
start walking down that road and then
somebody's like what about all this and
there's just such a machine that keeps
pumping things into you but you're not
doing what you could be doing
and i didn't feel like everybody was
doing nothing done really no i think i
think back in the day there was one or
two because i think about the old i
thought i was the exception that you
were special yeah yeah and i think it
switched to where you're left out
fomo yeah yeah and i remember i to
answer your original i
i remember back in 2004 2005 when the
ufc the ultimate fighting championship
started to blow up yeah and gyms opened
up everywhere yep and everybody's a
fighter i'd been a part of a gym for a
while and
they filled up real fast and then they
emptied equally as fast because people
realized oh they punch you in the face
this is not fun this does hurt oh they
kick you yeah and so i think there's
something about
unfortunately part of wisdom is getting
hit in the mouth and i think you've got
to put some money into bitcoin and lose
every penny of it thinking you were so
smart and that's how you realize huh if
someone didn't teach you out of the gate
about humility and wisdom and hey we won
this this time but not this time um i i
think that's a real important lesson
either you confer that or you just got
to take it if you don't have a model for
it right
yeah but i'm just
the cause is what i was the root cause
uh from a psychological perspective so
it is fomo
uh it can be or you know if you're
missing out or it can be um i think
we're i think we're pride that we're
special or you know i'm different i can
do this but we're wired to the least the
the least restrictive
road right yeah that's the way we're
wired yeah and that's not necessarily a
bad thing you don't want to take a paint
on to take paint on that's weird yeah
but uh but this idea that that um
yeah i know i know 99 of the
millionaires turned become millionaires
this way but not me i've got this i've
got it yeah there's something just
whacked about that and i was one of them
i did that i fell into that it's an
arrogance of sorts and i talked about
this on the maturity tied with arrogance
on the documentary same thing playing
the lotto i had a history professor who
um we were talking about d-day and i i
looked at it he was a strategist uh
strategist a military strategist and
i was looking at d-day and i was like
man
why didn't they just send 30 or 40 000
of our top troops into
into d-day and my professor's response
was because any
they would have looked at that and gone
this is not a good situation this is a
tough wave after wave situation
and i said well what kept all those guys
going they all thought they weren't
gonna die and he said pure old-fashioned
18 year old arrogance they both looked
at each other and they looked at the
right and the left and said sucks to be
that guy because i'm coming home when
they sit there and told you eight out of
eight out of 10 out of 10 of you aren't
coming home i think there's just
something about being 18 19 20 21 you're
invincible you're ready to go take on
the world and that opening scene in
private ryan oh man i stood on top of
that beach just looking at the gun torch
can you imagine 3 500 men died on omaha
in like 17 minutes instantly yeah they
just obliterated yeah
and uh yeah there's something about that
we'll just keep going we'll just keep
going and that's what happens with these
waves of get rich quick yeah as they
come through
and they come through about twice three
times a generation roughly but i hadn't
seen one like this one in a while this
one's very interesting
but um
because it's mixed in with this
existential crisis around
uh around covid where everybody thinks
everybody suddenly realized they're
gonna die yeah and so we're just here
for a vapor and you mix that with a
little inflation fifteen percent no it's
not seven percent all right you know
which means he's been reading the gold
side or he's been reading a bitcoin site
because the actual inflation rate is not
fifteen percent
seven percent's not good but seven
percent i mean in carter we had 12 right
so i mean
i think it goes back to if
surround yourself with wise people
because they're going to be able to tell
you if their heart rate doesn't get up
hey yeah inflation seven if your broke
beer drinking buddies are all that you
have to help you analyze your wealth
building process you're screwed that's
right
yeah absolutely or if the internet is
the other only source you've got which
is even worse right yeah because they're
trying to make money off of you well and
you know worse than that they're wrong
you know it's just like it's that's the
other problem is it's just inaccurate
it's uh it's it's bad information most
the time i mean not everything on the
internet's bad information but this idea
that there's like
you know my generation ascribed
uh my parents generation ascribed
uh
complete credibility
to any
news man on cbs walters
if walter cronkite said it
that's right there with like jesus said
it yep that's it it's done
this generation is wisely believes
nothing the media says
because nothing they say is true
um
i mean nothing they say it's true it's
pretty it's like our local newspaper if
you read it in there you go i wonder
what really happened
every time i read it i read articles
about people including myself i go who
is that guy i don't even know that guy
they just made that up how did they
where did they get that information they
just just dreamed up a story and put it
in there and so it but it's just this
generation because so journalism is
completely lost to credibility it
doesn't have anymore but this generation
then
not this current one these 19 year olds
they're smarter than that but the
probably the millennials they think
everything on the internet was true
and so the big joke was you know
everything on the internet's true hey
but abe lincoln you know described you
know describe the quote abe lincoln and
so uh but
you know but we're starting to realize
the source of information is not there
it's not true and so what you've got to
do is you have to get around people who
have proven
track records
of actually doing the thing you're
talking about that's right and um if you
want to be a really world-class parent
you should not hang out with people who
have parenting theories right or bonkers
kids or kids that are all you know off
the dad gum reservation where the in
asylums or the inmates are running the
asylum but if you see a family that's
functional and the children are not
they're not little step for children
they're not devoid of personality in the
name of discipline but on the other hand
they're not running around the
restaurant swinging from the chandeliers
you know they've got a personality but
they they're respectful they're also you
know they seem to be functional children
on the way to adulthood that'd be a
couple to sit down and have dinner with
and talk to about how to be a parent
because they actually are doing it right
same thing with the marriage you know i
got to spend time with mr truett kathy
before he and ms gene passed away and
um i remember i was we were in long
beach speaking at this um speaking of
chick-fil-a thing and we're up in the
suite with him and um bubba and trudy
and uh dan their three kids and a bunch
of their grandkids and stuff
and i'm talking to them because i just
i'm enthralled at that point i think
they've been married 67 years wow
and so we're walking along the concourse
you know down through here these
80-something-year-old people and i look
up and they're holding hands
and i'm like this is who i want to talk
to about being married that's right
you know one time
67 years yep i want to talk to them
about being married now you'd ask you'd
want to ask her mr true kathy about a
lot of different things there've been a
lot of things to ask him about but i did
i asked him and i asked her i said
because sharon was with me i said so
miss kathy how do you uh
how do you put up with a an
entrepreneurial man like this all these
years
and she just those eyes lit up and she
smiled and she said
patience
[Music]
[Laughter]
did sharon give her name in sharon's
dancing yeah you're right
why and put why is people in your life
good wise
this is silly this is silly this this
the way we're disseminating information
in our culture is completely broken now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your
relationships your work your money and
your life this is the ramsay show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five when you get ready to file
your taxes
don't use a junk product to quote file
for free only to find out later you got
upgraded six times and they tried to
sell you a bunch of other stuff
this is how some of these big online
filing services do it
so we got a problem with that so we took
matters into our own hands and we
launched a product called ramsey smart
tax how's it different well for starters
you get everything you need up front
there are no hidden fees no hidden
agendas we're not trying to sell you
something else
just get your taxes done right online
for less
now if you've got complicated taxes you
ought to go to one of our tax clps if
you've got an easy tax return go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax to learn more
and you can put your old tax software on
notice done with you
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax neal is with us neil is in
nashville if i hit the right button he
would be try it again let's see there he
is hey neil how are you hey great thanks
how are you better than i deserve what's
up well dude hey um just wanted to thank
you for your awesome advice through the
years my wife and i have been deaf brief
for five years
and uh we're on the investment step
great and um
yeah so the my question is we're going
to get a fairly sizable inheritance in a
few months
and we want to pay off our house
and there that will
pretty much cover the
the balance of the mortgage and
my question is there's just been you
know different schools of advice that
we've had
about like maybe taking some of it
investing half pay off
just invest the whole thing et cetera et
cetera but we like being debt-free and
we want to pay off our house good do it
so
yeah okay what do you what do you owe on
it
uh 240 000. okay
good and how much is the inheritance
uh roughly
about
250 000. okay
who passed away
uh my mother
i'm sorry man sure about that yeah it's
okay that's okay so um was she was she
good with money
oh god no no where did she get 250 000
to leave you
uh well um
my son helped out she they sold her
place when she moved into uh care home
and so she just had a house that she
that that's what this came from okay
that's correct yes and then um
one of the ways i judge stuff like this
assuming the person was a functional
person
um i always ask myself is is mom in this
case in heaven smiling when i pay off my
house
i would think she would be yeah yeah
yeah or maybe in other ways is mom and
heaven smiling to no knowing that her
son is free
his spirit is lifted he's sleeping
deeper in the night his marriage is is
is going full throttle right what does
paying off the house mean to you and
your and your wife
uh it means being even more debt free
there you go you know than we already
are yeah and it's stable and
you know you don't have to worry about
the next version next variant coming
through or whatever you you're not not
at least not you might medically have to
worry about but financially you don't
worry about it so that kind of stuff
it's a whole different thing right so
way to go man yeah so here's let me back
up just two steps then the decisions
made and you knew what to do you just
need somebody say it out loud okay
now but let's um
not like you're going to convince the
other people necessarily
because they've already got their
opinions and usually those convinced
against their will are of the same
opinion still but let me tell you what
what the data says
not what someone with an opinion says
the data says this
we did the largest study of millionaires
in north america
ever done
over ten thousand of them
in-depth airtight research
almost 70 to 80 percent of them which is
most of them
followed this
simple
case study they sounded like this okay
it took them 12 to 17 years to get there
in your case they got you got an
inheritance they didn't okay but in
almost every case they had two things
that made them hit a million dollar net
worth
they had a beefy well-funded
retirement account their 401k their roth
iras and that kind of stuff and a paid
for house
right
more millionaires were created by that
combination than any
other thing we found
anywhere more than entrepreneurism
more than
gold or bitcoin which precisely zero
percent was the uh precise percent that
did that
um you know more than more than uh more
than uh i borrowed on my house to invest
and the money i made on investments made
me a millionaire which is what's being
proposed to you that you should do but
your heart told you you didn't want to
and my point is the data says that
you're right and whoever's making that
proposal to you is wrong
right if that gives you any further
comfort on the decision that you've
already made
so
data you know is truth
truth is an important thing
i know when you're dialing these things
in but it's not helpful when you want to
buy a new truck dave
i can't stand data when it goes against
what i want it to say yeah it's not
helpful when i
when i when i i want to flex my
intellect rather than my wisdom exactly
and there is a difference all right
let's go to brian in
houston hey brian what's up
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
good apologies i'm super nervous but
i'll get through this quick no problem
so uh
my wife and i we we we had our i had it
moment last year and we grinded and
we're gazelle intense all last year and
long story short where
um debt free on baby step three as of
like a week ago good for you dude
where'd it go how much you pay off
uh about 50 000. yeah
get them
i like it yeah
so now and um shortly after about a week
later we found out we're pregnant with
our first child of course you did of
course you did that's how that works
well done
yep so that's awesome
so we my wife and i would both love if
she'd be able to stay home with our
children and the baby's due in
september
and
right now my income is 60k combined with
my wife's right now it's about 1 15.
and on my own my base i should say is 60
000 and we have a weird bonus structure
where we get a bonus
kind of halfway through the year and a
bonus at the end of the year
and that can be anywhere between like 10
and 40 000 on top of that
so my question is
i'm just looking through our finances
and with going down to one income come
september
i just want to make sure we'll still be
able to do baby steps four five and six
on just my income because i'll be able
to we'll be able to fully fund our
emergency fund and save enough for the
labor and delivery of our child
um but i just want to make sure i'm
doing this correctly
you're fine
there's two two things are gonna happen
one is fifteen percent of sixty thousand
is less than fifteen percent of a
hundred fifteen thousand at baby step
four so you're that's automatically
reduced
and your kids college savings you've got
plenty of time uh it's gonna take you
longer to pay off the house because you
got half the income you used to have so
that's part of the equation what i do
want you to do in addition to what
you're doing
um is i want you to practice
not using her check at all
okay between now and the baby because
you're not gonna have our check
won't you won't you run the house on
your butt on your income
and set her check to the side to do some
of these other things that you're
talking about that are one one-off
things
and practice running the household on
your check
for nine months
and because you're gonna feel how tight
that is you're cutting your income in
half it's pretty big
you can do it you can do it and if it's
what you want to do i'm for you i want
you to do it
okay but um but you need to feel that
you need to
there's a reality to that
and sometimes that reality means you
start looking around the houston area to
see is there other jobs i can make a
little bit more money or is there a way
i can make sure i'm on the higher end of
this bonus structure
uh twice a year when it dumps out but i
love that idea of practicing dave that's
that's a great idea you get to really
feel it and see those are real numbers
making them work it's a different
different thing man different thing
congratulations though brother you
worked hard to get to this moment and
you're like i wanted to and you did it
this is amazing congratulations very
well done very well done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
proverbs 28 19 whoever works his land
will have plenty of bread but he who
follows worthless pursuits
will have plenty of poverty
oh we kind of been talking about that
ouch martin luther king said if you
can't fly then run if you can't run then
walk if you can't walk then crawl but
whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
absolutely
dr king
amazing mind
an amazing mind amazing probably one of
the better orators uh in history lincoln
churchill king yeah uh and not only that
a quote machine for sure yeah uh but
that's i love that quote i've used it
for years if you can't fly then run if
you can't run then walk if you can't
walk then crawl but whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward the
other one i loved was if you want to be
a street street sweeper
sweep the streets in such a way that the
angels of heaven proclaim there was a
sweet street sweeper i can't say it yeah
stumbling over my words but yeah if
you're gonna do it do it with excellence
do whatever it happens but he paints it
with such poetry yeah you know
amazing julia is with us julia is in
tampa florida hi julia how are you
hi dave i'm doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
all right awesome well
um so i have lived in tampa florida for
most of my life um
my mom
who's disabled also lives here and i
need to be able to stay here and live in
the area and basically
since last year i've been searching for
a house because i've been ready to buy a
house now
and with so many out-of-state buyers
coming down here paying cash paying a
lot over asking i have not had any
luck with getting an offer accepted for
a house that i've really loved
and so i'm really afraid especially with
this year being predicted as tampa being
the number one hottest market in all of
us really i said i'll be priced
i didn't know that that's what i've read
that's whatever internet dave internet
that was written by the tampa newspaper
that's right the tampa real estate
association wrote that
yeah well it's a hot market but i don't
i doubt it's the hottest market in the
united states it's but it might be in
the top 20 for sure it's your question
still stands though it's hard to find a
house and it's getting really really
frustrating and almost a little scary is
that what you're saying
well that's not the only thing so i'm
really afraid that i'll be priced out of
the market for something good within my
price range the longer prices rise and
i'm not able to buy in which case
eventually i won't be able to buy in
this area at all if i wait um and so
should i just find something as quickly
as possible even if it's not exactly
what i want no no
anytime you get desperate right after i
get desperate i get stupid and right
after i get stupid i get broke
when you get that when you get that kind
of a mentality going you're getting
ready to make a mistake every time i do
i make a mistake have you ever heard of
the word catastrophize
i have yes so you've painted a picture
like right now it's hard
you have something that you really
really want and it's hard to get ahold
get your hands wrapped trying to keep
slipping through your fingers
and from that narrative you have painted
a picture of the next year two years
five years ten years that are all cute
disaster yeah and none of that's true
that's not
true so here's what what do you do for a
living
i work well i used to work on project
management and now i do recruitment
yeah you make good money
um not as good as in project management
but i really had to get out of that
because it was just really stressful and
i couldn't do it any longer um and now i
mean recruiting isn't
well i have to kind of start more of the
at the you know entry level so i started
60 but i'm moving into 70 and 80 pretty
soon so
if you actually became a recruiter you'd
make six figures right
um it depends i think if i work in i.t
recruitment or even if i recruit
engineers for big companies those are
definitely in the six figures
okay so here's my point if you're on a
career that is increasing
your career is increasing
percentage-wise faster than the housing
market is
percentage
follow the numbers follow the numbers
let's do facts okay facts when you go
from 60
to 100 over three years that's a 40
increase houses are not going to
increase 40 percent in the next three
years
your numbers are moving faster than
housing is moving
your ability to afford a house it may be
the same house at a higher price but
you'll be making more
and um so i want you to slow down two
beats keep looking
but promise yourself you're not gonna
buy out of desperation or panic
because you're gonna make a mistake if
you do
promise yourself you're going to buy
only when the right deal is there
as a person of faith i always just tell
myself that's why when it all works is
when god wants me to have it until then
he was holding the right thing i just
hadn't found it yet
and i really appreciate that i think i
just needed to hear it because um i feel
the same way
just um i really need to hear from
somebody so if he can if he if he can uh
you know if he knows when the sparrow
falls if he can number the hairs on my
head he can get me a house
especially the number of hairs on my
head
not a big job yes 11
11. how'd you know john don't be telling
all my secrets
gosh
no secrets on radio unbelievable hey and
julia i'll tell you this um my wife and
i looked and looked and looked when i
took this job and you did you went
through about seven of them through your
fingers yeah we had my time you ended up
getting the best one though got the perf
it took nine and a half months and we
got the one but we had to give our
realtor a pretty sizable tip because she
was great but we got the one that we
wanted hang in there you did kind of
have talked yourself off the ledge
during that
it gets frustrating as crying it will
and i almost made a couple like i'll
just replace the whole this or and even
you help me say dude don't do that walk
away from that so i
just be patient
and an apartment is okay yeah apartment
you can still be home you know if you
don't just say throw up your hands and
go i'm not gonna look anymore just keep
looking yeah and just make a game out of
it and it's just i hadn't found it yet i
just hadn't found it yet and i'm gonna
find it and when i do it's gonna be
awesome and earlier in a segment we
talked about the difference between
wants and needs
you need a place to lay your head that's
an apartment
you really want a nice house that meets
all of your wishlist it's going to go up
in value let it be a want and make it
the right one yeah yeah i'm not doing
this until it's right that's right and
even in this crazy market it's hard all
around you have lost their mind you be
the one that doesn't yeah be the calm in
the storm that's right julia that's um
uh what is that old song that oh rudyard
kept in kipling oh rudyard kipling yeah
yeah when i saw you become a man my son
but when all about you have lost their
way i had to memorize in the sixth grade
and i've forgotten it now
but uh yeah then you've become a man my
son yeah but uh in this case become a
woman my lady
but yeah the uh um yeah just don't don't
lose your mind just because everyone
else has
and that's true chasing something
running from something
uh it can be fomo it can be greed it can
be fear it can be pride
um
and isn't it interesting that these
character qualities negative though they
be affect your money more than the math
almost always yeah math is easy it
doesn't change
yeah and it's just this person in my
mirror is my problem
and the the wiser he gets i don't know
if he's going to get smarter but the
wiser he gets
the the fewer
money problems he has
and uh the calmer you don't sweat the
small stuff and oh by the way it's all
small stuff
you know it's that thing right be
anxious for nothing yeah
be anxious for nothing
and uh it's but that man it's so hard
because we live in a culture this is
driven by acquisition it's driven by the
newest shiniest thing it's driven by the
latest technology and fear fear fear
fear and driven by fear there's a lot of
fear out there right now
people are and they're mean when they're
afraid i've noticed
some of you people in your covet stuff
bless your little hearts you're just
mean anger anger anger anger that's mean
i know you're afraid but but just be
afraid stop being mean you don't have to
be mean while you're at it oh my gosh
i mean and during the height of that
stuff man the way people were dressing
people down in grocery stores and
everything else is out of control
yeah it's it all does come back to that
and it does end up being reflected in
in your money and in your goal setting
julia you're going to be fine slow down
about three heartbeats
you're good just just be an assassin
just be an assassin
slow down and go find that right thing
and just drop it you got you got this
you can do it
dr john deloney james
ben
austin in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host is it austin it's austin it's
austin got it right today we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you